[Musique]
c'est cool le temps que ça serve je le
fais déjà dans mon jardin
[Rires]
je suis pas surpris je trouve ça bah
bien une bonne initiative
bah apparemment l'urine on fait pas mal
de choses avec dans le monde dans lequel
on vit le gaspillage il y en a marre
j'achèterai pas les carottes extrait de
mon urée mais c'est beau on va uriner
sans se poser la question où est-ce que
va finir la piste là pour le coup c'est
une très belle nouvelle donc
[Musique]
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on utilise
l'urine comme un milieu de culture pour
des micro-organismes qui vont faire
monter dedans et qui vont se concentrer
par milliers et qui ensuite vont
permettre aux plantes de capter les
nutriments dont elles ont besoin dans
l'environnement azote phosphore
potassium etc on est les seuls au monde
aujourd'hui à faire fermenter l'urine
humaine et à le transformer en deux
fertilisant agricoles
[Musique]
va tomber par gravité dans les tuyaux
que vous voyez là et ensuite il y a une
pompe qui va aspirer l'urine dans ce
qu'on appelle des IBC qui sont derrière
et c'est dans ces IBC qu'on a mis notre
produit stabilisant pour que l'urine
elle serait propre et pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'odeur
[Musique]
donc ça tout ça ça vient de la Fête de
l'Humanité donc c'est arrivé en camion
[Musique]
ça c'est de l'urine classique et là ça
va être du produit transformé et donc ce
qui fait que c'est opaque c'est parce
qu'à l'intérieur maintenant il y a des
micro-organismes qui ont poussé des
bactéries vivantes qui vont avoir un
effet dans le champ
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour faire un hectare de blé
en moyenne en France on utilise 300 kg
d'engrais azoté si on veut remplacer ça
par de l'urine brut c'est sans aucune
transformation c'est possible ça a été
démontré mais il faudrait mettre 30 ml
par hectare ce qui est énorme avec la
transformation avec le process toupie ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit à
l'agriculteur ben écoute tu vas réduire
de la moitié des engrais minéraux enfin
de 30 à 50% tes engrais minéraux tu
rajoutes 25 litres de notre produit et
tu as le même rendement quand on voit
les les limites planétaires qui ont été
franchies notamment sur le cycle d'azote
cycle du phosphore cycle de l'eau enfin
tous ces cycles là en fait on les on
pourrait quasiment j'exagère un petit
peu mais on pourrait quasiment tout
régler en recyclant les urines
[Musique]
faut avoir du recul là dessus donc je
sais je peux pas dire je peux pas dire
exactement on en a jamais utilisé je
suppose que ça s'était jamais fait
encore jusqu'à présent donc bon après
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas essayer nous
on a profité de la révolution agricole
des années 60 alors c'était de faire tes
on a doublé les rendements et bon
aujourd'hui d'autres sources de
fertilisant serait plutôt bienvenu
et voilà pour économiser
les engrais importés peut-être pour
favoriser la vie biologique et des sols
je suis dans une optique de rester en
bio et de développer plutôt des
nouvelles techniques et économie d'eau
économie d'un train et donc ça peut être
une idée pour
pour fertiliser les sols en fonction des
éléments que ça apportera bien sûr
[Musique]